BJ Novak played dunder mifflin employee
Ryan Howard during the offices long
network run but he hasn't latched on to
an equally high-profile project since
the series left the air that doesn't
mean he's been sitting idle however this
is what BJ Novak has been up to while he
definitely isn't appearing on TV quite
as much BJ Novak never left television
the year after the office ended Novak
had a cameo on the comedy community and
a recurring role on Aaron Sorkin's the
newsroom playing Lucas Pruit the owner
of the company airing news Knut along
with a bit of voice work for the
animated show Arthur Novak enjoyed a
recurring role as Mindy's ex-boyfriend
Jamie on the Mindy project and played
the satirical version of himself on two
episodes of the musical romantic comedy
series crazy ex-girlfriend well back to
the old ecstasy Factory Novak is also
doing a lot more work behind the camera
particularly in terms of his work on the
Mindy project just as he did for the
office Novak has worked as writer
director and producer on the Mindy
project which isn't surprising
considering his long history with the
show's creator and star Mindy Kaling BJ
Novak was showing interest in more film
work long before the office shut its
doors winning small roles in 2007's
comedy knocked up the buddy drama rain
over me released the same year the 2012
political satire The Dictator
the most visibly as one of the few lucky
survivors of Quentin Tarantino's 2009
bloodbath inglorious basterds with the
exception of the series finale Novak
wasn't around for the offices last
season and his film credits are probably
a big clue as to why Novak was busy in
2013 the offices final year doing more
work on the big screen he reprised his
role as Baker Smurf in 2013's The Smurfs
2 that year he also had a small role in
the comedy the internship and a meteor
role in the comedy drama saving mr.
banks the latter film revolves around
the development of 1964 is classic Mary
Poppins Novak plays songwriter Robert
Sherman who with brother Richard Sherman
co-wrote the film songs the following
year Novak played Alistair Smythe in
amazing spider-man 2 a character who may
have eventually gotten some spotlight if
the franchise hadn't died Smythe is the
supervillain called the Spider Slayer in
the comics more recently Novak appeared
in 27
Dean's the founder about the creation of
McDonald's as Harry J Sunnah boy the
McDonald's corporation's first president
and CEO in 2013 BJ Novak's signed a two
book deal with publisher Alfred a Knopf
and the following year his literary
career premiered with the short story
collection one more thing stories and
other stories the book enjoyed a six
week stay on the New York Times
hardcover fiction bestseller list the
concept is that I wrote a book so now
I'm all pretentious people think you're
pretentious anyway the Washington Post's
jen cheney described Novak's writing as
being gifted with the style part stephen
wright and park charlie kaufman married
with a sharp ear for and satire of
contemporary pop culture the next book
BJ Novak wrote targeted an entirely
different audience released after one
more thing stories and other stories in
2014
his children's book the book with no
pictures spent fifty five consecutive
weeks on the New York Times picture book
bestseller list if you're wondering how
a children's book that advertises it
doesn't have pictures might appeal
children well block wait what that
doesn't even mean anything the beginning
of the book explains quote everything
the words say the person reading the
book has to say no matter what the rest
of the book in large colored letters
then forces the presumably adult reader
to say ridiculous things that get the
kids laughing like quote I am a monkey
who taught myself to read or quote my
head is made of blueberry pizza in May
2015 news broke that BJ Novak and Mindy
Kaling were going to collaborate on yet
another project and this one wasn't
going to be on television the same month
the Mindy project was cancelled by Fox
and subsequently picked up by Hulu the
New York Daily News reported that Novak
and Kaelin had signed a 7.5 million
dollar deal to write a book about their
off-and-on romance
the following month Kaling talked a
variety fare about the deal saying she
and Novak didn't quote know all that
much about it yet she explained that
they were still in the early stages with
the book and they weren't completely
sure where they were going to
go with it save for the fact that
according to Kaling it would be quote
great and funny in spite of what some
may have assumed from the New York Daily
News story however Kaling said that
while she and novak would be talking
about the romantic relationship as well
as the friendship that the book quote
won't be a tell-all so far nothing has
materialized as a result of the deal to
keep your eyes on your local bookstore
after he appeared as McDonald's first
president and CEO Harry J sana born in
2017 s the founder in a totally Ryan
Howard s move Novak decided to make life
imitate art just like his founder
character Novak is hoping to become an
innovation supporter of meat Novak told
w w DS Kristen Tower
this sounds sci-fi do you know about the
companies that are using meat stem cells
to clone meat in a lab Novak went on to
describe the process saying it was
possible to take the cell of an animal
and quote grow and grow and grow it
meaning that as opposed to the high
numbers of animals butchered for meat
now quote you could just get one unlucky
cow and feed the world forever Novak
says he supports a number of companies
doing the work and singled out Memphis
meats is one of them man Dwight would be
so jealous I can get you exotic meats
hippo steaks giraffe burgers
we'll talk check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]